okay
hello everyone what's up welcome to
simulation series my name is Alan Saki
on I'm your host simulation pairs
together global leaders with humanity's
most thought-provoking questions and
you're tuning in to get inspired by
these deep questions and hopefully build
the future of civilization today we are
featuring a day or se wow that was easy
we are with in bio trillion which is an
emerging health tech company based out
of San Francisco and simulation series
is grateful for their sponsorship and
venue Thank You bio trillion Lincoln by
Oh check it out add a links gonna be in
the bio Deo has a really cool background
a Deo founded the funded a Deo founded
founder Institute you can find those
links in the bio let's get a real quick
little bit out of what those were oh
I've been an entrepreneur for 25 years
so those were the latest things that I
did they're just efforts to give back
time for inertia so I've done everything
from start a media company in 1994 that
migrated online to help launch the
XPrize and and send private exploration
into space and then later on started
giving back to other entrepreneurs by
launching the funded which allowed
people to research rate and review
venture capitalists and then the founder
Institute which helped start about
1,500 new technology businesses per year
in about 200 cities around the planet
so that's badass 1500 over the last how
many years ten years right no no no
we've created over three thousand we
should create 1500 in the next 12 months
I mean if it goes well it would be 2,000
if there is some sort of global disaster
maybe 800 companies but between 800 and
and 2,000 I say 1500 is a safe bet and
this is this leads me right into the
first question so again we're gonna ask
these deep thought-provoking questions
we're gonna get your answers on them the
first question is about how we maximize
human potential and I really think that
founder Institute I've been working with
you helping mentor some of the
entrepreneurs for about a year or so and
I've I treat this as a way to maximize
human potential it helps people become
self actualized that makes them they
bring something to the world
yeah how else how else so yeah I've been
working on that for a long time
Alan since I was 18 and then so so I
started my first company coming right
out of college in in my early 20s like
22 and have been building companies ever
since and and every initiative that I
have done
in building something has been to unlock
human potential and and they've all
failed so I'm a complete zero for 10 you
could say on that the XPrize failed we
do a high five for failure have you know
you can give me a high five because we
hide we love but you can't you can't you
know you know the thing is that I
learned you know I've had conversations
with a lot of smart people about this
failure is not a great way modality of
learning right because there's usually
one or three ways to do something
correct and and it really almost an
infinite way a number of ways to do
something incorrect so it's much success
is a much better modality of learning
especially learning from other people's
failures etc yeah I'm learning from
other people's failures is certainly
more efficient because usually you can
read about it in a few minutes versus
experience it over the course of years
but yeah so look they all failed they
continued to fail but they've had some
success and it's debunked a lot of myths
that you have about helping people
realize potential so how so well man is
MIT myth you know I'm not entirely sure
that
so the first thing that I think I've
discovered through this process is that
most people are asleep and you know it's
I don't even think they care so this
whole concept of unlocking human
potential there's almost an 8 in
sumption that someone wants to do
something to make their life or the life
of people around them or the lot of
humanity better and that is wrong I
think if you take the average person and
you say you can go push a boulder uphill
and your hands will bleed and it will be
really difficult but when you get that
boulder up the hill on you you know
you're gonna make a dam it's going to
save this and that uh or you can sit
down and watch Netflix I think they'd be
like ah sit down and watch Netflix and I
think that that's you know seven point
nine nine nine nine nine nine nine nine
billion times out of eight people will
make the Netflix decision over the
pushing the boulder up a hill decision
but all of the meaning in life comes
from taking responsibility and trying to
make the world a better place
cleaning your own room first getting
that nice and tidy and then helping
other people I don't know if I could say
all them and I'm not trying to be
negative you I'm just trying to be
honest right I like you know I don't
find that and I keep trying so I leave
that it can be done so so so first you
know the operating assumption that
people want to do something is false
they don't the the next thing that I've
learned through the processes of doing
it is that it's not you can't there's no
mass media way to do this there's no
like I mean it's it's theoretically
possible that if like a nuclear bomb
went off that might wake a lot of people
up very quickly but my guess is that
would wake a lot of people up very
quickly who were near where the bomb hit
and yet the mass of humanity would still
be asleep so you know the net effect of
that wouldn't be very power question
then should be how do we quickly awaken
more people to find meaning in their
life and help other people build a
better world how do we quickly do that
entrepreneurship is a great one you're
up to that so speech so I I think let's
define speed by
you know time okay so a fast awakening
for a human being is probably a year or
a trip on LSD courtesy and sadly so so
psychedelics increase openness and
openness leads to a higher likelihood of
awareness but the those are all not like
direct correlations so if you take
psychedelics you it's the only known way
in psychology to increase openness
openness as a big five personality trait
is one of the traits that leads to
greater awareness again over time yeah
so if you took like a big dose of
mushrooms and and the known the known
psychedelic is mushrooms I'm sure it's
probably true for LSD and others so if
you take a big dose of psychedelics and
then you go on a journey of trying to
open your mind I still think it would
take in the order of magnitude of months
Vivian Ming says this really well she
talks about how long it takes to build a
human into the world and it takes a long
time to mold a human and if you're
molding a human to do things that are
repetitive tasks you're molding a human
that is gonna take another dozen years
or so to train into a different creative
problem-solving skill set that is not
going to be as easily automated and this
I just want I would say I would say look
the speed is a year and you can't do it
it's just some lessons I learned are the
following it's not nothing that I've
seen or tried is able to make it happen
faster than in the order of magnitude of
months when you put those months
together we're look
around a year let's say you had a direct
person that you were mentoring that you
loved and you thought they were very
inspirational very young he could still
mould their mind into the world and you
kept them with you maybe 40 hours a week
to help mold their mind maybe you could
do it in three months you think no so
here's what the here's what the problem
is right everything about you is wrong
right so your mental model of the world
is wrong right so you you're like oh
like well the earth orbits around the
star that's not wrong all right you know
yeah it's more complicated than that
right and so like a lot of times you buy
into these like simple truths the
dynamism and you know how I see this all
the time with people that I that I
mentor helped and they had they set a
mental model up for the world and I'm
not saying that I have the best mental
models my mental models are right but
like out like a lot of human beings
mental models for the world
are shaped from the world itself versus
let's say from first principles so for
example
how do you how do you get to work well I
you know I can I can take a car I could
take a bike I could take a train to walk
I could find a jet pack right okay well
why do you need to go to work at all
right why do you need to commute to work
right why not put work near to where you
let me like yeah so you know the first
the understanding your world from first
principles and then building up you
start to realize that a lot of these
things that you're taking you know I
want to fix transportation well I'll
tell you what the easiest fix for
transportation is yeah I'm home
move people closer to where they work
you have a transportation problem done
you know the swalot so first principles
initial first principles is crucial and
I think you carry an interesting view I
do you've had 25 years of it's in your
life
so you've seen so much of this non first
principle action that's caused you to
feel this way that it's difficult to
mold people into their maximal potential
well it takes it takes a lot of time
right because a lot of things like just
the example of transportation that we
went through kind of went through that
really quickly but you know for you to
understand what that means to the way
you think about the world huge takes a
lot of time huge right you can't just be
like oh yeah yeah just click right yeah
so and then that's just one thing dozens
of variables for that what we eat how we
live how much we welcome with how we
speak how we use social media yeah we're
not honest with what no-one's honest
with one another no one's on us we're
going another they use I call it like
sheathed shroud of this language that's
very like non accurate like how are you
doing great what you're great really
what does that mean like you know what
the one word explanation I'm a human
being sub subjective first-person
experience in this crazy world I'm great
okay so what is that like what's with
sue sue sue but you know so if you
really want to unlock I love being a
stuffed dog stuck on this yeah uh-huh so
if you really want to unlock human
potential and like every piece of
someone's framework is broken it's not a
matter of oh let's shadow me for a few
days and suddenly be unlocked yeah I
mean as I said I think if a nuclear bomb
went off over there and I managed to
live and I have to reframe my world I
might be able to do that in less than a
year but other than some really
catastrophic thing like that happening
it takes time and that's where you see
all these different companies that are
being formed that hopefully affect how
you use language or how you use food or
how you use transportation well yeah and
you know but that's change so I'll give
you an example a very practical example
of even that so a lot of founder
Institute 80% of all the companies that
we've created are live at the founder
Institute they're about 3,000 what that
means like 20% of them are dead and if
you look at a lot of times the the
second or sometimes the third company
from a founder is really good because
they don't even have the awake mental
models to form a good company
the first time out of the gate totally
and they need to go through this like
failure well kind of it's not I would
call it
failure I would call it learning not
even learning more like this waking up
it's a waking up right right they've
been it's a hibernation business into
the world bears don't come out of
hibernation like the killing machines
they're like wake up slowly into the
right flow yeah I mean don't get me
wrong they are killing machines with it
there's some transition you know and so
I think maybe to be even more precise I
think there is a moment or something
that happens or the human being that is
that that breakpoint from I once was
asleep and now I'm awake right and it's
like key and that's like okay but then
there's this last one part of the
Rubik's Cube moving and then there's
right but that for them to actually be
awake and like consciously working and
designing and doing things that feed
into their purpose in life and their
soul and the meaning of the world that
takes that takes time enhancing their
perspective of the world so they can
become more awake and build better
systems for future okay that was
insanely incredible I mean we unpacked a
lot there I really appreciate your
perspective that was a shame yeah I mean
you say you say it's easy and that's
exactly the opposite it's like 25,000
variables that have to be put in to
maximize human potential at least I mean
there's so much so ok let's go let's go
to what do you think is the most
beautiful thing in the world
I think is the most beautiful thing in
the world man I should have read the
question mark you don't have to I mean I
do to read but I only read some poor
thing so no no no I unfortunately not
that important I wish I had time to read
important things what is the most
beautiful thing in the world right now I
think the Z button because this is so
awesome sponsor
no I mean you know so it again you have
to almost give a time parameter on that
because to some extent I think we're in
this is you know okay
driving here I think this bridge is very
beautiful yeah and and I'm sitting next
to it looking at it and it's majesty is
greater yeah I've seen it from below now
I've seen it from different angles
yes I drove right in and and kill me
looking at the bridge and my friend did
the lighting on it and I was thinking
about the lighting I'm like this is a
really it's a massive it's a massive
thing the job manatee made that but but
in another way it's also kind of bad
because it's like the old mode of
transportation so but at that time it
was gin the time horizon of like the
last hour - now the bridge is something
that I thought was incredibly beautiful
amazing and probably one has certainly
gotten me thinking about a lot of things
yeah transportation direct like art
because of what my friend did on it in
and then you know you can always look at
things in time horizons because I don't
think
I don't think time exists but it does
for us
you wanna hack that a little bit further
so time only exists because we have not
transcended uh-huh so if we had achieved
our ultimate potential and or died time
would not exist because it's not
inherently and and it's something that
exists it's it's a construct of our
perception of what's around us and I can
go in yeah cool that even further so
okay so beauty if you look at if you
look at these progressions if you look
at why we exist right my thesis is that
there was once one thing and it didn't
really know what it was so it split into
two and half of it is on a journey to
find out what the other half is now
we're on the journeying half right ergo
we have things like time but there are a
lot of other things on the journeying
half if you will that don't have time so
time is just a construct in our design
principles to transcend and that
transcendence is on the quest to figure
out what what we are what I am or who we
are you know there's a lot of questions
that could be asked there so you know in
the ultimate beauty I think is that
question right
Who am I right or or what am i that that
I think is the ultimate beautiful when
when you leave when you leave time well
you know no no I don't know actually
that's it that's an Indus script answer
that's not actually again built on
constructs that may or not may or may
not be true the concept of an atom isn't
even people are like Adam is is is is
matter and then they're like well atoms
really aren't matter they're kind of
energy and then like so really we're
just like maybe a better descriptor if
you go the cutting edge of science would
be just like a bundling of energy and
then what the hell is that is that your
soul like what is that we're bundling of
energy is consciousness localized in the
human nervous system
oh that's not really a good question so
to make the question better well if you
wanted to make the question better you
might start with what is consciousness
ah and then there might be and there
might even be a better one is is there
consciousness which might go first and
you say so good
I don't know that consciousness exists
at least as far as any model that we
understand it conventionally-speaking so
you know human beings are our programs
right and then there are questions of
the manipulation of the programs right
there are soft manipulations and hard
manipulations so if I took a hammer and
I whacked you in the head and I damaged
your frontal cortex that would be a hard
manipulation and you would definitely
act differently from then forward you
might lose your filter or whatever else
so they're hard many of you but they're
soft manipulations right you can have
you know someone
you know con you out of money right so
they're soft and hard manipulations and
their various degrees in between like
the population of Afghanistan has very
low fluid intelligence because they've
been malnourished so nourishment affects
consciousness and in like hammer right
so it the mish the human machine which
can be programmed right it can be
programmed through nourishment can be
programmed through again soft and hard
means so you know and then you have your
genetics inter playing with the
environment so I'm not entirely sure
that consciousness exists I think that
which then leads to some other questions
right like the later ones but but so I'm
not in time so I'll start with does
consciousness exist I would say big
question mark I'm not sure and and you
know I think therefore I am
let's say that we're all programmable
machines and there's hard and soft ways
to manipulate these machines and let's
say that we were set upon a journey with
the destination in mind and then let's
say that that destination hadn't been
reached right which is why time exists
so you know it's hard for me to think
how conscious we are because true
consciousness would mean that we're
actively trying to do something and I
don't really see anything that's
conscious about anything okay like we do
stupid things to hurt our own
self-interest all the time right
every day we drink stuff out of things
that will kill us we eat things that are
known to poison us la la la like you
know we don't do things and I've been
saying that those are good examples but
like a consciously driven society would
be very different from this society
right for sure like there's no question
I think we live far away from where we
work so we build machines that kill more
human beings than anything else to get
to work like
what I think is that that sound like a
smart thing to do no how did that happen
it was someone like Wow I have a great
idea so the more conscious of society is
the closer they get to utopia I'm just
saying I am NOT I'm not even at that
level of questioning just yet I'm just
at the level I'm not entirely sure that
we are how conscious it doesn't mean so
like it doesn't mean that it's
completely unconscious I just don't see
it being very conscious either so we
might be in what best could be described
as somewhat of a tween state right where
there are signs of consciousness but
like weak sides it's like I think he's
alive I see some some some breath coming
out the nose maybe maybe it's alive but
like some like weak signs of
consciousness not like strong sides like
we occasionally don't do incredibly
stupid things but then we do like drop
they're not there there might be some
good like Obama Trump how'd that happen
thank you no and I'm not saying Obama
was great and I'm definitely not saying
Trump is great but you know what the
hell I think it doesn't even make sense
it's like what is like oh look
interesting like woo little breath oh no
no boss I thought I saw a glimmer in the
eyes I thought move move it
do you do that was Asian
okay so consciousness do you think that
artificial intelligence do we have an
existence worth saving
faint dimmer I mean look to be fair our
group I if I wanted to be absolutely
abstractly correct no I am an obvious
him you do I am and I'm not being
optimistic today cuz I'm gonna look I
had to drive here and I get was soured
my mood a little so not but I'm not I'm
not not optimistic I am optimistic I'm
gonna be there's a difference like so do
I believe in humanity's ability to
transcend yes am I gonna sit here and
feed you a load of cow poo about things
that are you know just to be optimistic
no you want it you ask the tough
questions I'm gonna give you some
answers you so it's important to get the
real stuff but I'm not gonna mystic
stuff Wow you know so you if you haven't
asked an optimistic question yet what
does
thing in the world I did I said it was I
said it was in creation well no I said
that if in the time span a very recent I
would say the bridge and in the time
span of eternity I would say the
question of Who am I and and that's an
honest answer you would say like a
flower is this consciousness worth
saving so well that's suit so
essentially when you ask about AI it's
entirely possible that the grand
achievement of humanity is to build
something that that is better than we
are and wipes us out possibly but that
could be you know it's entirely possible
that our grand achievement is not us but
the thing that we create and the CEO
Google says is more important than fire
it's more important than electricity
it's a greatest human invention well he
he has his own issues but that's an
aside we don't need to go down the
personality problems of certain leaders
but look which most people have many
here's what the issue is right so we
should not be it again we're doing
things that are inherently dangerous in
and we don't understand and we don't
have control it would be it's the
equivalent of giving your children a box
of m-80s and a Zippo lighter a torch
like every kind of flame device possible
and being like kids whatever you do just
go have some fun and they're like sweet
like you know if they come back with
half their head blown off and you're
like whoa what happened you're like oh
you know that's really your fault and
we're basically doing
five thousand nuclear warheads on the
planet and we're basically doing that
with a lot of stuff right now like AI
genomics food production transportation
we're basically you know doing very very
dangerous things with the fate of
humanity
now mapping the brain traveling through
space those are those are generally not
so I'm just saying like there's the when
you experiment with things and you don't
have checks and balances in place
generally agreed principles intelligent
ways to control them that can very
quickly undermine the entire existence
of humanity I don't consider that that's
a little bit nerve-wracking and as a
result some of the smartest people on
the planet who are conscious or trying
to be conscious have sounded the alarm
that this is concern it's in place okay
coming to this checks in place it also
impedes innovation at times as well
where you whereas you have China that
may not have any checks in place they
can just run with genetic engineering
the United States may fall behind in
that regard yeah but you know okay so I
you know you want me to be optimistic I
agree I should be optimistic but you're
you're asking questions that are a
little bit again sort of generally
pessimistic it's not the the optimistic
view is like oh it will all work out
great and and maybe it will maybe it
will all work out maybe but if you have
unchecked
unthought through group of people
[ __ ] around with human genomics you
could introduce something that wipes
humanity out very quickly very quickly I
mean you know lots as serious as it gets
right very quickly yeah I mean cold
spread around the planet you know the
AIDS which you really have to like have
unprotected sex there has to be blood it
spread like wildfire this is like not an
easy disease to spread you could take
the effect of AIDS and genetically
insert it into a virus and then you have
something like Ana bola even that could
spread around the planet like a cold
right and you could design it so that it
lasts just long enough that the
transmission rates really high and and
white people out and this if you
consciously try to we could accidentally
do that and that's why I think it's like
an AI is no better right like the
average cellphone intranets you just
said that genetic engineering disease
could potentially be as harmful as
artificial intelligence of proliferation
if we're not smart about how we think
and do these things with checks and
balances and and and I don't mean I just
mean being smart right I'm not talking
about like you know you know there's no
fail so if AI comes online right there's
no failsafe to stop it from spreading to
every device on the planet within
seconds and that's what it will do right
it will be on every device within
seconds there's no way to stop it right
now
and people are developing the AIS on
open networks which you know
even if it were on an open network my
guess is that it you know that that's
not very good but even if it were you
got it on a closed network it would
probably spread in Overton network
anyway
but like wouldn't you develop my eye on
a closed network first just to be have
an extra buffer layer right it seems
logical to me but and and then there you
think that that would be a lot of people
think does not having an AI next thing
is like genomics similar stuff like
people are screwing around with diseases
and genomes and viruses and everything
else well you know the I've heard tell
about that the deep classified stuff
that that's that's out today and you
know that's pretty hardcore stop so just
to give you a sense of what I heard is
capable it's in this is entirely
possible that this is already having
that you've gotten a cold that cold has
infected you with the virus that will
stay in your system and that virus can
be activated to kill on a unit of one
using a bunch of conventional
technologies now that technology is
activation technology exists the
question is whether it's been released
or not it's entirely possible it has no
one knows right because let's say the US
government they know if we released it
but it wouldn't know if the Russians
released it or not or if it was stolen
from someone and released by someone
else so you know we're screwing around
with things that I think we as human
beings need to say this this is why so
I'll tie it all together right we're at
this sort of in between this tween state
of unconscious conscious
we're meddling around with a bunch of
firecrackers and torches
in a variety of areas food genomics AI
and this might be the the you know well
the the signs of adolescents like oh
right oh yeah but there's no mom or dad
they're like where are your helmet by
yeah okay so only teen year-olds in
puberty right now right without a parent
standing around trying and so I think
that right now more than ever like if
what look a and and the alt ID even back
to that conscious awakening thing it
takes about a year for someone to wake
up and they're probably gonna do some
stupid adolescent DS stuff in that
interim period and then start so you
know I think the world today needs a
complete rehaul on how it's being run
you got to find the people that are
awake like and been awake for a little
while and have them in some sort of
intelligence supervisory like safety
like wear your helmets on and they're
not they're not going to be telling
people what to do but more like advisers
or guides or mentors like hey you can go
screw around with this but if it goes
wrong you could kill all of humanity so
I would recommend that you do this this
and this and like oh thank you that's a
great idea because a lot of these things
aren't that hard right they're not that
hard to do right you know developing AI
on a closed network like just unplug
take it off what you know Ethernet cable
you know it's not like this is yo and if
you want to go to extremes if you go
right you genetic
and open space was a closed yeah I mean
some of these things are relatively easy
to do right and sense as to what people
eating lots of over periods of time does
to someone do it in a small small small
sample not all all of humanity or worse
Monsanto is planting genetically
modified wheat and you're looking at the
levels of celiac the levels of gluten
intolerance going up it's like well let
me guess
like we're genetically modifying wheat
and it's affecting the populations that
the genetic modifications in a food
product that are for it to be more
insect resistant or for it to be we
don't know resistant and I know we don't
know because we haven't done a
longitudinal study I've been talking
about this also for a while but then
there's you know food evolution that
came out yeah well if we can't we get to
the point where we can't eat the food
does it even matter I was asking them
about this question as well but they're
having do these longitudinal studies we
don't know if you make a hundred genetic
changes inside of the genome of we you
know what actually ends up occurring to
us when we consume it for 50 years we
have even 5 years right like we should
have never been it's like oh wow look we
made short wheat that can grow faster
and has more volumes let's let's get it
out there it's like no no no no feed it
to you feed it to a hundred people for
two years or 500 people for two years
make cereal blah blah on small batches
if it works out and there's no you know
maybe go to a wider study or planet in a
region but it's like we make this
discovery and it's in the field and and
you know it's like suddenly you know and
then they're like oh you're stolen my
you know they you know Monsanto tests
and then had well they patent and they
test fields and it's stuff you know
germinates across a field and then
they'll get the other farmer to have to
pay
it's just it's just we're not being
smart your analogy about kids or
conscious maybe it's a better witness
your analogy about kids being half
conscious and us all humanity basically
being like kids with these tools that
have developed into our world that
enable us to potentially extinct
humanity
we don't have a parent or an advisor or
a guide that's helping us out
also there's the interest something else
really good earlier thankful thank you
really good earlier it was about it was
about this whole I think I covered a lot
of them you did you did it was really
good about the youth and about how we
weren't awakened yet oh I wanted to
mention this I recently was entering
more into Peter Till's kind of group and
they were talking a lot about mm bend of
benevolent people guiding the world and
I think that kind of relates to what you
were saying as well there's these that
maybe advisors or guides that have a
very conscious role of the existence of
humanity and the systems of humanity and
they're able to help guide people these
young 13 year old adolescents you which
is you most of humanity into maybe
mature 24 28 32 year old adults so that
we can prosper better well I don't know
I don't know if we're you know we're a
long way from 32 but maybe were like
eight and we might through some guidance
get some 12 year olds to help us get to
nine I mean that we're nowhere near 32
32 means I don't even know what society
would look like if we had the
equivalent of 32 year olds closer to
skin no no no no no no humans this idea
it's not utopic like we just we you know
it's it's you you we can't even think
that that you're you're asking something
that no human could conceive right and
it's like and not only that it's like
bleeding edge science fiction that like
Star Trek Star Wars stuff like that
that's seems to be like very far-fetched
but in many ways it's based on our
modern modern model they're good people
they're bad people above all but you
know when you're talking about and so a
32 year old when we're in our eight or
nine maybe ten you know that's different
it's a vast you can't even imagine so
for example I'm not sure language would
is the language that we know won't exist
for long and it certainly wouldn't be
around if a bunch of 32 year olds were
you know in terms of the developmental
age every 30 just just earlier today I
was learned that how can we have this me
to thing the
movement to me two movements going
simultaneously with rap music and
hip-hop music that's like hoes money
[ __ ] but I'm like they can't coexist
those two things
well language language you know lot
actually I think coexistence is you know
I've been putting a lot of thought into
things like coexistence and I do think
coexistence is the future of humanity in
that there will be things that coexist
with one another that are incongruous
with one another so someone believes in
God and science in one person that
happens today yes or you might have a
god group and a science group but they
won't be butting heads so co-exist and
women have parallax we see things
differently but that sounds build a
better society well so Co so I see
coexistence as a positive future trade
but language language itself is is is
fundamentally broken it's very
inefficient thirty what would what would
your a deal like language look like you
know well I know you're all
civilizational language it would be so
in theory right a 32 year old language
would resemble a very powerful shorthand
programming where I could say to you
something
and it would be the equivalent of a
civilization that exists for you know
many hundreds of thousands of years so
and I would be like I would save you an
equation and you would understand this
yeah you'd be like oh yeah humanity
maybe maybe that could be maybe but in
fact let's try let's try right now okay
so so the size so that so the mat maybe
the the mass of the earth the mass of
the Earth orbiting this star and then
when things evolved on this planet and
then what so all all all of so all of
this all this could be easily described
with you know probably two variables
time and mortality something like that
time and and and transferred because you
know if you look at so so but I think
there are a lot of other variables there
may be other variables in this but I
mean this is basically immortality okay
so you're measuring the lifespan of
civilizations across sort of like time
and hat like that there's this concept
of time right so time can exist and then
things don't don't necessarily change
the way we do in time but we we seem to
have this or this this thing and I'm not
talking about life I'm talking about the
whole of all of this time I hid that by
Isaac time and mortality so that just
things don't continue to exist in their
current state forever whether it be a
human being
anything really so that mortality might
not be the right word but that's what
I'm saying like we don't even know no
way good buddy you think there's a
communication method that's really
fascinating okay either the 32 year old
had a 32 year old so quick question is
do you think that with these 13 year old
adolescents that are running around in
terms of consciousness being maybe have
developed or whatever do you think that
one of the reasons why we might be
trying to move to space or move to Mars
is the potential threat of this
civilization erupting on itself and that
way there's at least somewhere else that
people are living
well okay so I want to be conscious of
time because we're coming up on an alley
yeah I wanna I saw I'll try and answer
this so I've been working on space for a
while I've been working on space for
almost 18 years and you know I
originally got in for because I thought
if there was some dramatic thing that
happened in humanity like it could wake
people up that didn't happen but there
were other reasons that I like space and
my views on space have matured quite a
bit but I'll tell you what my my current
beyond space is here um it's there's
actually a good show on the sci-fi
channel called expanse and it captures I
think it's a very realistic view of what
space looks like in kind of kind of dark
but in and I'm not being dark but I
would want mobli not being dark but so
so the the you know we're gonna send the
best and the brightest and probably the
conscious people to Mars
absolutely so if you know it will be a
society built from the oldest and most
capable Souls among us they will be
breeding with each other
correct and so it's entirely I used to
have a lot of other thoughts as to why
space was good but I'm now basically at
the the belief that it's it's a single
greatest shot that we have of creating a
conscious society from scratch from
scratch that's a really interesting
perspective and that then then and you
know I don't think it's pop it's
possible it can happen on this planet I
think when you take this conscious group
of highly capable people and you put
them in a hostile environment and they
must collaborate and work that this
could be the great so like I think AI
could be a great creation of humanity I
think taking our most conscious people
isolating them in a harsh environment
yeah yeah and and watching them blossom
might also be but as I said I've done a
lot of things and they've all proven a
little wrong they could also just create
nukes and try and blow us up so you look
these idiots are bothering us why don't
we just eradicate them like oh okay and
that's exactly what happens in expanse
the war breaks out and like why you need
to have a war like you're just so far
away from each other so it's interesting
to compare the birth of a conscious
civilization on Mars to whatever the
Sentinelese people that would have never
encountered human civilization that they
it's a fascinating also a part of the
world now okay quick quick follow-up
question of Mars is this when we're
there in the first country let's say as
the United States has landed there
and then China is coming after them are
we playing nice if Russia's coming as
well are we working together as a world
are we working individually houses
working humanity does not have the drive
or capability to send humans to Mars
right now yeah it's
maybe one individual Elon you know
governments are if Elon does it which is
going to be very hard and he says he's
gonna do it in 20 22 to 24 and I take
him at his face on that I would put the
I would say I think Elon can do it
governments cannot they are subject to
elections and Qiang regime changes and
policy changes the following is doing it
CNS a Chinese National Space
Administration is doing it and they
function differently than the US
government okay okay so that's a simple
win this really needs this really needs
the concert' it's this isn't like oh
we're gonna go the mountains and hang
out this is like the single hardest
achievement humanity has ever done by
many orders of magnitude but Bay Bridge
is pretty cool though these are yeah and
don't get me wrong it's a beautiful
human achievement at the time this is
probably one of the great human
achievement and it's lasted forever yeah
but the reality is that that that the
crowning achievement and and here's the
thing we can't do it right now you don't
think competition will be a problem in
20 years in 20 years let's just
hypothetically say China and Russia but
in 20 years ago happens yeah I'm gonna
and they're gonna show up at to an
existing there gonna be a birth through
the land at the same base do they try
and make it different on a different
part of the planet
are we racing to colonize Mars are we
collaborating to colonize Mars ok so
again I go back to the expanse because
sadly I think what's gonna happen is
like you send someone to Mars in 20
years so let's say in 20 years from now
Mars will start to be colonnades
colonized in seven years two year flight
increments so there'll be people who've
lived on Mars at that point for like 13
years give or take okay so maybe 10
years whatever in that range 10 to 13
years these people are going to be
really different right they're not gonna
be like you and I correct and I'm not
entirely sure that you could take like a
earth monkey and land that person on
Mars I'd be like who's this [ __ ] now
maybe that'll be welcoming and inviting
in the beginning but it's hard to
predict what will happen like maybe for
like the first 10 years the earth
monkeys will be kind of welcome and then
come like 20 or 30 years when the first
Martians native Martians are being born
earth monkeys aren't welcome it's like
you're just too stupid different nations
we can't allow any more stupid people
you go into quarantine zone do you think
different nations will collaborate it
doesn't matter what we do here
that's what I'm saying they won't want
us there I wouldn't I have a group of
super smart people why are these earth
monkeys here they're so stupid what are
they good for farming labor death I
think you're asking the question the
wrong way doesn't matter what we want to
do we send the elite brains of humanity
who off to a place they'll live and
thrive as a society they probably don't
want dumb people showing up on their
door after a while because they're gonna
advance at a much faster pace we're sure
monkeys manage to build a second rocket
and send to her 50th rocket and send it
over if they're not gonna play and so
what ended up the nice thing about the
expansion expansion exactly the story of
this the earth has the population Mars
has the brand and that's also kind of
similar yeah it's like leave it but then
there's a twist to it all but basically
that's that's definitely gonna happen I
mean the fundamental and then the
belters who do the mining it which you
know I'm not entirely sure we're gonna
that's real there's plenty of mineral
assets that do early so this is a one
lasting genetic bifurcation class-based
speciation of humanity
so I don't believe in the Gattaca theory
of humanity per se right as I brought up
its an earlier the program right you
have environmental programming right
bashing of the head or malnutrition and
then you have softer programming like
how your parents treated you or whatever
else so you know I think that you can
take any thing right and in the right
environment any human and in the right
environment they can be great right they
can and should be great right and
they're gonna be great in different ways
that's not happening today people have a
this kind of a greatness that is not
being lifted out by the the environment
it's if anything it's being suppressed
right so the greatness of your design is
is not being realized now it's it's I'm
not sure if that it's gonna be any
different on Mars but my guess is it
will and so the average person on Mars
let's say going back to that will be an
environment where their greatness is
unpacked on a daily basis and realized
on a daily basis and then they're just
not gonna want like the earth monkeys
coming around they're like wow this
guy's really this nice seems like that
does sound like a base it's not it's not
a class it's not a class-based
speciation if you believe that everybody
has a greatness within them which I do I
believe that everybody has a not being
self actualized there's a lot of
dampening things there's a lot of noise
and self-actualize is part of it but I
would say remember there's the hard and
soft environmental variables as well so
it's you
and it goes back is there consciousness
but I would definitely say that
self-actualization is a part but it's
also a lot of the environmental things
that are suppressing as well so I do
believe everyone has that greatness and
so I don't believe in an inherent cloud
I do - I believe in that greatness and
every single person as well I think I
know your answer to this are we in a
computer simulation we are in a
algorithm our biochemical algorithms
control us probably a very simple
algorithm with the variables I mentioned
before beautiful alright thank you
everybody
beautiful view everyone thank you for
tuning in a day or se it's been an
absolute pleasure with you we can find a
Dale on Twitter of day or se thank you
for bio trillion for hosting us and
sponsoring us there links in the bio
again you can find us online simulation
series comm if you guys enjoyed this
content please do give us a like please
subscribe to our Channel we're gonna be
doing these podcasts twice a week we're
hosting a live event on February 17th
with jordan peterson in san francisco
it's almost sold out a 600 c theater
it's gonna be a blast
so do follow through with us check us
out keep in touch with Deyo thank you so
much for being with us too for us
greatly shortens a good friend you
should all go see him thank you everyone
that was easy oh dear that was fantastic